okay so in the last uh uh video
sal and i spent some time talking about
uh his reactions to uh this resignation
letter from gerald conte appeared on the
internet the other week what i want to
do in this uh conversation is go from
there to the first step in the writing
process where you actually write
something down that you're going to
probably keep going forward and that is
something that that writing teachers
call the thesis sentence and it's really
just the main point if you were to write
an essay about this
resignation letter sour to write an
essay about it what at the end of the
day would be the one sentence that would
capture its main point what we're going
to do just in the next few minutes is
talk about how you would go after that
so first of all before we do anything
formal sal as you're looking at this
what what are some of the points you'd
want to make sure you would make it
somewhere in that essay even if it's not
your main point you just want to make
sure you made some some points what are
some of the ones that come to mind what
is it what we touched on in the in the
last video which is you know this this
idea that you know
this is kind of painting a pretty broad
uh
a broad brush of of of what stem is or
you know and kind of uh i would say to
some degree belittles it you know it's
kind of a
you know seeks data-driven education
seeks only conformity i mean once again
i understand where he's coming from and
i think i understand and i agree with
some of his emotions of what he's
reacting against but i think this was
this was you know maybe a little bit
unfairly uh kind of picking on stem as
as maybe the reason for for a lot of his
his
angst okay so so by so that's gonna
probably lead to a thesis sentence it's
gonna have two parts one is going to
have a word like although beginning
which is going to acknowledge that
gerald has a point so although blob or
something
on the one hand or blah blah blah but
then
you're going to introduce your point
somewhere along the line which says
but
but or
or or or whatever so keep that in mind
i'll throw out another one i mean we
didn't get to it in the last video but i
doubly underlined this you know
particularly not at our school and i
think this is you know something that
you see a lot of i mean my sense is that
he probably was a very good teacher at a
very good school
where
when you do try to
overlay more rigidity on that you are
hampering his ability to be a great
teacher and being that but it's not
and i'm not you know i'm not an expert
here but it's it's it
it it's speaking to only one type of
circumstance i mean that there might be
environments where where you know where
a lot of the the motivations for the
micromanaging or the conformity or the
standardization is actually coming from
to to kind of de-risk environments that
are not as good as the environment that
gerald conte is working at so so it's
it's it's kind of this
you know there isn't one
classroom environment there isn't one
class of teachers
and and i mean one of my big beliefs is
that there's not like a solution that
can be applied wholesale to to all
classrooms or all contexts well the
irony says he actually was pushing back
against the one-size-fits-all mentality
but you could argue from at least one
perspective that he's actually imposing
a one size fits all from an elite an
elite education point of view
generalizing out again i went to very
elite educational schools i totally
empathize with it with what he's doing
but i don't think it generalizes and i
think the real struggles and the reason
we have all these challenges in society
is because it doesn't generalize and
then so what what might and by the way i
think the khan academy may be part of
something that might so i think it's
pretty pretty exciting well let's let's
say so you i heard two ideas i heard
something about the idea that you're
you're you're casting stem in the wrong
light
and then i heard i just get always
defensive on that good what stem isn't
just about yeah well yeah and by the way
as a humanities guy we tend to get
defensive the other way which is it's
stem sam sam scam and it's like goddamn
there's something besides stem
and you acknowledge that
a lot so so but i think that's great
which is getting them a perspective on
stem do you think your main point in
this essay would be that would you or do
you think you would step back and try to
also include this idea about um
uh the more uh you know what i'll i'll
say i don't elite education may i don't
want to in any way imply that that's a
negative i actually think elite
education is a good thing but but that
notion that it's more of a restricted
environment yeah i mean i think this
would i mean this i wouldn't talk so
much about the stem i mean i definitely
reacted to it a little bit but i don't
think that's even the main point of his
his uh
letter here i mean his the main point of
his letter is kind of what we you know
the micromanaging and the governance and
strangling his creativity or the
creativity of a great teacher and and so
i i think what i would write about is is
um
which is something i i speak a lot about
is you know whenever the system you know
whether it's a governor or politician or
superintendent gets worried about the
education system
their reaction is to place more
constraints on it
make it more rigid and and it might it
might de-risk some of the worst
classrooms uh some of the ones that are
really failing and
and where students aren't even getting
to kind of a minimal level uh but but it
has the
the the horrible consequences of what
what gerald conti is writing about where
it's also suppressing the very best
teachers and it's kind of a it's kind of
a march to mediocrity okay let's say i
think that's a terrific main point so
let's let's let's try to build a thesis
sentence around around that last idea
so
a thesis sentence consists really of two
parts a subject and a predicate or a a
topic and a claim that you're going to
make about that topic so what is the
topic of of of uh uh that you just were
speaking to a minute ago
that
that
i i i could understand the motivation of
officials to try to
de-risk
the
the the worst performing classrooms or
schools
but and and and the only way they know
how to do that is by placing more
rigidity and more standardization across
classrooms and more testing um
often superficial testing
but that has a horrible effect on
on the system as a whole because it it
also holds back the the best teachers
okay so the claim
although we haven't gotten crisp yet
about the topic we've gotten very crisp
about the claim the claim is has a
horrible effect on on the educational
system as a whole because it it replaces
constraints on the best teachers so so
if if the claim is has a horrible effect
on the educational system
what is the subject of that sentence
what has a horrible effect on it
so well and and let me know if i'm going
in the wrong direction here but so so i
guess what where i where i'm i'm
narrowing it on is i understand the
desire for people to
standardize and put the and and test i
understand where that motivation comes
from
but the solution that they're placing on
teachers like gerald conti in my mind is
not the correct one that there are
solutions that can
hopefully help you bring up the standard
of the worst performing schools without
necessarily
holding back the gerald contes of the
world okay all right so so so where i'm
trying to get to i'm actually getting
something more micro than macro so and
we're circling in on it so
the the thing that you have empathy for
but that in its current form is being
destructive we need to name it
yeah so and we need to give it an like a
noun phrase so so is it standardized
testing is it is it uh is it
governmental regulation
what is it that what what's the main
thing that i have empathy for well well
that's having a horrible effect on
education you're having empathy for why
people are doing it but at the end of
the day i think the thing that's having
the bad effect is the is the is the
rigidity and micromanaging or the
standardization let's call it
micromanaging and rigidity okay
micromanaging and rigidity
um but it's got to be some form of
governance right in other words the with
the
because well i guess you could say
micromanaging and rigidity are having a
horrible effect what's this kind of
notion of a top-down state mandated okay
i think curriculum
okay i think i think that's that's i
think top-down state-mandated
curricula that need to be followed to
the t
is the topic
now it's actually a big it turns out um
that what we're really saying is state
mandated curricula and then we've we've
we've added top down and we've added
that need to be followed to the t those
are modifiers but basically what we're
talking about is state mandated
curricula
and we're saying it it it
we have a a side
idea which is while it could help
de-risk certain classrooms in certain
situations so you you you it's not a
completely one-sided argument our main
claim is
what is our main claim about these these
curricula what's what's the most
important thing to know about them
that that they are holding back they
they are
suppressing the the gerald contes of the
world okay okay they they do hold
education back by suppressing the gerald
conte's of the world so we might have a
thesis sentence which says yeah top-down
statement curriculum you know that need
to be followed to the t you know
we might put in a like a comma for a for
a sort of a qualifying clause like while
you know
while helping what whatever your point
was while motivated to
while
which which might help de-risk some of
the worst performing classrooms okay
cool which might help de-risk some of
the worst performing club yeah there you
go
might let me scroll down a little bit
yeah
we have a little bit of ozymandias down
here which might help de-risk i don't
know how to spell half of these that's
perfect that's pretty we're not worried
about it we're not at the spelling part
of this writing we're going to do a
little hyphen here that's fine de-risk
the worst performing classrooms
yep
performing
performing classrooms yep
and also has a the impact of holding
back the very best yeah i wouldn't say
also i just say it has the impact
uh the negative impact or the thing yeah
yeah yeah whatever i mean i'm writing
for you
of
holding that's a good way to write just
got a famous author right you just
impact of holding
back back
holding back
the very best okay now we're not we're
not we're still very early in the
writing process so this is not the
actual sentence probably that will end
up in the last essay but what this is
this we call this a thesis sentence
because as we go forward in the writing
process we're going to try to organize
all the subsequent work we do to be in
service to some part of this sentence
and so as we as we build paragraphs
we'll build paragraphs around curricula
we might build a paragraph around
managing to the t we certainly would
build one around de-risking
worse performing schools and then we'd
probably build the bulk of our argument
around holding back the very best right
so i mean if i were to write this out as
i mean i'm thinking about this how i you
know with this is my thesis sentence i
would i would write a little bit about
the motivations of of administrators and
and officials why they why they're even
thinking along these lines and you know
that's all about the test scores and the
number of kids who have to take remedial
math uh the number of you know et cetera
et cetera you know all the things you
read in the newspaper uh uh but then i
would i would i would really focus in on
you know that might help a classroom
that's like this or that that's really
broken
but it's going to definitely hold back
that and then i would try to write about
kind of alternate solutions that might
be able to
address the broken classrooms without um
breaking the the the not broken
classrooms so there's actually another
part of this there's this could be a
second thesis we should close now but
this could be a second part of the
switches but there is a way forward
which is more creative and constructive
right right cool